first of all congratulations on this
show like an exciting moment or
collection of moments for you guys are
you excited for people to finally see
those ready tell me what it was like the
first time I met Mindy
first time well I'm at Mindy in my
audition I think as I saw her before I
went into the audition room because I
was in the waiting room and she was
leaving to go to the bathroom yeah and I
was like oh my god okay and then I was
like no put it together get together man
give me your best shot no one ain't met
her she's so cool yeah yeah I was I was
really starting to talk about oh my gosh
I'm gonna get like I am I gonna say I'm
gonna go up like Hello you know those
tic TOCs like yes how I'm gonna go up to
say like not going like like nation or
like this yeah but then when I went up
to her she's just so chill and so cool
yes I love her yeah one thing I love
about this shows like it's beginning
headlines from the jump and a lot of
that is the open casting call and how
this whole thing went down
I mean 15 thousand people write like
that
I mean you must be what came first of
all at home yeah what's the reaction at
home from Pam well even it's during the
audition process
I didn't originally tell my parents that
I was doing this yeah so when they asked
me to come to LA they were very
skeptical right cuz I was like yes I
said minos to some guy in LA and now
they want me to come to you on a netflix
joke so sounds a little sketchy yeah but
everybody back home is like hella hyped
no but cuz it's like especially for
coming from Mississauga like not known
for you know being booming for Hollywood
right except for some new bus you know
everybody's really excited cuz like
we're all on the journey together yeah
almost square one just has your back
yeah 100%
Oh square one you know now what's cool
about like the moment you started the
show the narrator that you hear is John
McEnroe and the idea is like his sort of
like antics in his temper mirror you
know your characters
in the same way did you get to meet him
yeah we did yeah I had like this
completely different idea of him in my
head like professional tennis player and
then when he walked into the room he had
like a flat cap and chains and he was
wearing like a baggy like I said and
some glasses and I was like all right
cool yeah the snow I think is going to
be for a generation of people something
that like I mean I never had a show like
this one that could speak to you know my
experiences who I was and you're gonna
be getting a lot of that what do you
think about that like how do you project
that's that's gonna go are you already
hearing from people even before seeing
this show there's well over 15,000
people wanted to be a part of this yeah
and that shows enough that this is long
overdue and that it's gonna it's a
wanted people want this well I've been
waiting we like even struggled to find
characters that we can really relate to
in our childhood no Bree well you know
looked like me when I was watching TV
that sucked
yeah but now we're able to give that and
that's the best feeling yeah yeah I mean
with this show with so many others and
so many movies coming out - you really
feel like we're finally pushing that
needle where we're getting to see more
stories told from all different
perspectives I think we're starting to I
don't think we're nearly done yet and
nor are we gonna stop fighting for that
yes but we're starting to again yeah I
feel like it
awesome thank you so much guys thank you
thank you